en san josé costa rica se llevó a cabo
la cumbre extraordinaria de los países
que conforman el sistema de integración
centroamericana y españa tras la llegada
del jefe de gobierno español pedro
sánchez a costa rica la cumbre se enfocó
en la recuperación sostenible de la
región tras la pandemia de kobe 19
soluciones para los efectos del cambio
climático y la migración los
participantes reiteraron en particular
la importancia del multilateralismo la
integración regional y la cooperación
internacional este mismo día se llevó a
cabo un evento de solidaridad para los
desplazados forzados de la región en que
se anunció la contribución de 110
millones de dólares por parte de españa
eeuu la unión europea y otros países en
conferencia de prensa los presidentes de
guatemala y costa rica se pronunciaron
sobre la situación en nicaragua donde ha
escalado la crisis política tras el
arresto de aspirantes presidenciales y
opositores al gobierno el presidente
guatemalteco pidió la liberación de los
detenidos mientras que el presidente de
costa rica calificó la situación de
preocupante y abogó por su abordaje en
la organización de estados américanos